[Music]
this episode of shots of awe is brought
to you by the Toyota Prius let's lead
the way
in biology when there's a mutation and
that mutation is expressed in the
organism and it turns out to improve
that organisms capacities to survive
then that ends up being a good idea that
organism will replicate more widely than
others and that idea will spread
that's biological evolution now with
cultural evolution we went from trading
and genes that were good ideas to
trading in memes that hopefully are good
ideas we've also empowered individuals
all over the world to disseminate their
means at the speed of light this makes
us crucial players now in what's going
to happen in the future like we are now
the number one replicators of ideas that
can transform the world and we serve
biological evolution with this cultural
evolution the membrane of mind that has
overcome the planet is one in which
ideas are literalized through technology
through transformation through all the
things that mankind has done as a force
of geology so ideas matter and so what
are the ideas that you're going to
spread into the world what are you going
to pay forward what is the possibility
what are the good vibes what are the
grand visions that you are going to
utter into the ether sphere into the
mine sphere and this is something that
all of us should be thinking about every
single time when we tweet or share or
post or publish we're co-writing the
future story we decide what happens
you